amana well a young Frenchman converted
to Islam years ago he says it wasn't an
easy decision and that his search for
truth let him down some wrong roads are
flooded wobble day mostly in the
moderate mosques they told me to
approach it calmly and take my time but
I'm idealistic the world is often unjust
and I wanted to move it forward faster
and so I started looking in the internet
and that's easy one website leads to the
next third and so I ended up on the
extremists pages that got on this bad
trip really Oregon few people are
willing to reveal I've had contact with
extremist circles such a move can be
dangerous Islamist preachers don't like
to let someone off their hooks the
Internet is the meeting place one of the
people active on it is omar onsen the
Islamist agitator in France we Muslims
are a huge community more than one and a
half billion people among us a very
special group the chosen ones they're
like foam on the sea doo doo nah man
Thompson's rants have led 700 young
French people to take part in holy war
or jihad in Syria most of them come from
atheistic families the jihadists always
use the same method on the internet they
show the young people shocking images
that paint the Western world as
degenerate and corrupt from the Corporal
people become convinced that there's a
huge conspiracy among the Jews the
financial industry and America they
develop a kind of paranoia and see evil
everywhere so Papa Horvath Dominic bones
son Nicola listened to the fanatic
preachers he went to Syria and half a
year ago killed himself in a suicide
bombing his mother isn't shocked and
regards Nicola as the victim of an
unscrupulous network out of the blue a
text message arrived
son was now with Allah the Yakuza popul
Vuh Luca I didn't even receive his body
I want to go to Syria and bring back a
handful of the soil in which he's buried
so then I would at least have something
in abling me to mourn him so you from De
Luca you know these Pied Pipers are
active in many European countries in
France they're attracting increasing
numbers of young people so now special
police units are looking for youth who
cross international borders the French
government commissioned the sociologists
dunia bizarre to train officers to
expose the perpetrators methods since
then she receives threats from the
Islamists and is under police protection
her job entails passing on information
to parents as well as investigators it's
already getting uppity Islamists forbid
people to eat western food and they give
them a long list of foods to avoid they
tell them to throw away their parents
alcohol and perfume to tear any curtains
bearing pictures and not to listen to
music D'Ablo this manipulation is
intended to isolate the young people
when they've been softened up enough
mediators with airline tickets to Syria
contact them once the young people have
reached this point it's almost
impossible for them to change course
they feast on particle you money the
girls often go off to Syria believing
they'll be doing humanitarian work there
then they learn about people being
slaughtered and they phone home and cry
they never get over the shock once they
arrive in Syria most of these young
people are already lost the mother of
Nicola ball had given up trying to
persuade him to leave the Islamist group
her son was already living in another
world Jabbar krunal there was stronger
than the mother's love link then this
danger wasn't recognized or talked about
I was lost I was all alone
an old friend showed him unwell that he
was no longer thinking for himself he
managed to leave the sect that had roped
him in while he was still in France just
in time to tell he read also hit that is
pre in visual I realized that my radical
views we're not worthy of any religion
neither Islam nor Judaism or
Christianity the whole school nothing
for ultimately my Islamic faith rescued
me the Quran says seek peace within
yourself that's what those who want to
go to Syria have to be told a man well
knows the tricks the Islamist preachers
use who target young people now he wants
to serve in the struggle against jihad